nous avons du coton, nous pouvons produire toutes ces
choses dont nous parlons sur le
marché de l'occasion ici en Ouganda et nous
avons des entreprises qui ont commencé à
produire si vous allez dans le parc industriel B
si vous allez trouver des fileuses nocturnes et
d'autres qui arrivent euh  peut être capable
de remplacer ce truc plutôt que les
fermetures de seconde main dans un laps de temps très court
donc s'ils viennent nous brûler en
premier, nous allons perdre nos
emplois subvenir aux besoins de nos familles, ça va
être très
difficile
[Musique]
et la bonne chose  cette
originale, cela affectera d'abord
tout le pays parce que nous recevons beaucoup de
taxes sur les vêtements d'occasion, c'est
l'aspect général de tout cela, puis sur
les gens qui s'occupent de vêtements d'occasion, la
plupart d'entre eux  ont une bonne
qualité par rapport à ceux des
nouveaux dans les magasins, c'est pourquoi nous
préférons choisir le Viet, ils sont bon marché, les
gens peuvent facilement les fabriquer, ils peuvent les obtenir à des
prix moins chers,
tout le monde peut
acheter des vêtements bon marché mieux que ces nouvelles
chaussures.  nouveaux
vêtements [Musique]